ça y est maintenant c'est presque fait
tous les aoûtiens comme on dit sont
partis en vacances de leur nouveau port
d'attache temporaire il nous imaginent
nous qui restons dans la région du nord
désabusé peut être triste mais surtout
privé de soleil
ben laissons les imaginer ce qu'ils
veulent le soleil est là et il est bien
là depuis presque une semaine
le thermomètre va et vient autour des 30
degrés il a même taquiné les 33 degrés
sous abri du côté de cambrai en quelques
jours il est devenu le principal sujet
de discussion on en parle beaucoup et un
de nos soucis numéro 1 maintenant c'est
mais qu'est ce qu'on peut bien faire
pour se rafraîchir
tous les moyens sont bons bien sûr mais
le meilleur reste quand même un bain
soit en mer soit la piscine soit tout
bêtement chez soi et puis après cela il
y à la boisson en ce domaine
il est des gens heureux en ce moment et
patrons de bistrots pour eux c'est la
bonne saison on vend de tout et beaucoup
mais au fait dans la région qu'est ce
qu'on boit quand il fait chaud les gens
ont soif avec le beau temps on vend des
diabolos main les diabolos ce titre or
on vend des vittel on rend des jus de
fruits mais enfin quand même il faut
dire une chose c'est que la bière étant
la boisson préférée de la région on en
boit quand même
habituellement on emploie une on en boit
2 bat mathieu on en boit droit ou en
bois 4
est ce qu'il ya une heure pour boire de
la bière en jetant spawn un nom qui soit
11 heures qu'ils soient midi qui soit
six heures due au manque on a chaud on a
soif on boit de la bière
vers la
moussu taquinera depuis j'entends tu me
dis tu mets
mais à force d'en boire de la bière et
surtout s'il continue à faire aussi
chaud on se demande si comme en 1959 et
bien une vingtaine il en manquait je ne
pense pas du moment qu'ils deviennent 59
ce n'est pas tout à fait exact les gens
faisait la queue les grossistes
attendait peut-être deux trois quatre
heures pour avoir de la bière par contre
en 1913 d'après les souvenirs que on a
de la profession il a nettement manqué
de bière dans le nord il y avait plus de
guerre du tout
comme vous pouvez le remarquer cette
année ce ne sont pas les réserves de
bière qui manquent
il y a des stocks et les livreurs
continuent leur tournée donc cette année
malgré la chaleur qui persistent et qui
incite à bord les gens du nord ne
manqueront pas de leur breuvage préféré
et puis la bière ce n'est pas mauvais
pour la santé à condition d'être
raisonnable bien sûr le comité national
de défense contre l'alcoolisme dit même
qu'on peut en boire jusqu'à un litre et
demi sans danger pour la santé
ça fait quand même si bonne chope et de
quoi se désaltérer dans une journée
et puis pourquoi s'en priver puisque si
nous mêmes ici dans le nord qui la
fabriquent ou et on en fabrique beaucoup
mieux fait la production en hectolitres
y en a ici nous faisons un million deux
cent mille hectolitres c'est à dire nous
faisons environ 25% de la production du
nord qui est de 5 millions d'hectos 10,5
millions des taudis de ça représente
combien de personnes environ 120 litres
pour le nord et pas de calais donc
chaque habitant du nord bois 120 litres
de bière par an bébés compris deux y
compris la grosse vacances non c'est
plutôt mois de mai juin quand il fait
très beau mois de mai juin c'est là
notre plus grande pointe à bien une fois
le cash
une fois le 15 juillet c'est déjà moins
on dit que la bière fait transpirer mais
enfin on n'en voit quand même ça va
faire du bien
j'ai trouvé
nous